le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
jeunes arrivants sur le marché du
travail bénéficiaires de minima sociaux
travailleurs handicapés certaines
personnes sans emploi ont en plus des
difficultés professionnelles et sociales
particulières pour leur venir en aide
le département met en place des ac ay
des ateliers et chantiers d'insertion
janica 55 ans après ces temps
d'inactivité il vient de signer un
contrat d'insertion et rénove les
bungalows du village de corail à saint
gilles
m
les bungalows s'appelle les plaines
c'est l'assurance au monde enfin de
rénover pâture enduit c'est pourtant
bien loin de la fraîcheur des plaines
que janick embauche tous les matins cet
habitant de fleurimont travaille depuis
le mois de mars au village de corail à
saint gilles ce centre de vacances gérée
par le département propose aux familles
des bungalows en bord de mer la
structure est actuellement en cours de
rénovation
le village corail n'avait pas été
rénovée depuis dix ans je pense qu'il en
allait de soi puisque c'était une
demande de
ma des touristes des gens qui viennent
qui est des utilisateurs mais aussi
le département a au fil devoir
d'entretenir son patrimoine depuis le
début du chantier
janyk et ses collègues ont ainsi rénové
17 d'un galop comme celui ci c'est avec
une pointe de fierté que les ouvriers
présente le résultat de leur travail
menuisier de formation janick vient de
passer sept ans à la recherche d'un
emploi
avec l'âge ce père de famille signe
finalement un cdi
un contrat à durée déterminée
d'insertion pendant au moins un an
il va travailler à la restauration des
hébergements du centre ce chantier
d'insertion et le premier mis en place
par le département
généralement les plus anciens sont
peut-être porté aussi par une pop une
par une association et ça c'est le tout
premier chantier d'insertion
porté par le département alors
jean-pierre d'intention c'est quoi c'est
des contrats en cdi c'est à dire contrat
assorti d'une formation plus poussée en
fait que des contrats aidés normaux et
les autres aussi sont sont plus
conséquents sur ce chantier
ici les ouvriers cessez donc à
différents travaux avec eux rendus en
béton armé
la faiblesse du vent en fait pas que le
tableau même preuve des nouvelles
compétences et surtout un an garantie
d'activité pour janick c'est un
soulagement après une longue période de
chômage
sur ce chantier les ouvriers viennent
d'horizons différents mais partagent la
même motivation celle de travailler
laurent fait la route tous les jours
depuis saint denis la distance ne le
décourage pas voilà deux ans qu'il
cherche un emploi ne peuvent adhérer
je faisais un peu d'intérim en famille
une petite fille de 4 ans ça m'a aidé et
du coup ça au mauvais à l'époque
des personnes qui ont été choisies pour
ce chantier d'insertion sont des
règlements d'heure d'emploi de longue
durée qui ont besoin de souvent une
petite qualification supplémentaire ou
même une qualification tout simplement
pour pouvoir accéder à l'issue de ce
chantier à un travail pérenne
transformer cette expérience en vraie
opportunité professionnelle
c'est l'objectif de toute l'équipe en
attendant la suite tous poursuivent leur
mission avec enthousiasme et bonne
humeur
le contrat à durée déterminée
d'insertion est un contrat d'une durée
minimale de quatre mois renouvelable
dans la limite d'une durée totale de
deux ans la rémunération est au moins
égale au smic
le contrat d'insertion s'adresse aux
personnes au chômage
rencontrant des difficultés sociales et
professionnelles particulières pour plus
de renseignements vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site du département ou
www.cegedim.fr